[Musique]
musique romantique et défilé de robe de
mariée pour la première fois
particuliers spécialiste se sont réunis
pour échanger à l'occasion du premier
grand salon du mariage un événement
inédit pour le département c'est parti
d'un constat Lindsey annonce 50% de la
population mariée sur le 78 on regarde
beaucoup de lieux de prestige beaucoup
de prestataires et pas de salon du
mariage que les prestataires connaissent
le territoire ensuite c'est tellement
plus facile d'échanger avec son
prestataire quand il est pas très loin
et enfin
le fait de pouvoir prendre le temps
parce que c'est cocooning c'est c'est
pas une usine c'est pas une usine bien
que celui de l'année prochaine que je
auquel je pense déjà sera plus grand
mais malgré tout il restera esprit
cocooning il y en a pour tous les goûts
tenu de cérémonie sur mesure pièce
montée traiteur et même faire par
stylisé l'objectif du salon est clair
centraliser et simplifier l'organisation
du mariage
le lieu d'accueil de l'événement n'a pas
été choisi au hasard selon l'Insee près
de 5000 mariages par an ont été célébrés
dans le département une aubaine pour
cette créatrice
fait partie des grands départements on a
les plus grand nombre de châteaux et de
lieu de réception pour les mariages et
pour les grands événements c'est
important d'être visible surtout dans ce
département-là plus accessible que les
salons parisiens trouvaient son bonheur
ici et plus simple les futurs mariés à
la recherche de conseils ont de quoi
faire de cette fête un moment
inoubliable on a en plein préparatif
pour notre mariage j'ai ma future femme
du coup Morgan qui m'avait dit qu'il y
avait un événement juste à côté de chez
nous à 5 km donc on s'est dit que
c'était l'occasion en fait de passer
pour voir un peu ce qui était proposé
notamment au niveau des robes de mariée
pour le costume de mari aussi au niveau
des tenues pour le voyage de noces les
services pour les bars tout ce qui va
avec le salon a tiré environ 300
visiteurs eux aussi vont peut-être
succomber au charme des Yvelines pour
célébrer leur mariage comme l'ont fait
par le passé Brigitte Bardot à
Louveciennes ou Jamel Debbouze à cerné
la ville